you've got to take a risk you've just
got to be out there so what i help
people do is be a little brave and pick
the words for now this is not a lifetime
commitment this is not marriage
[Music]
sandra clark thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you
hi excellent thank you a little warm
today but otherwise great
definitely definitely a little warm it's
definitely some interesting times that
we're living in 2020 continues to
surprise us
but over these next 20 minutes uh you
are going to help me
become a little bit more knowledgeable
about linkedin so
a a professional platform that most of
the people that are listening to this
use it's something that i definitely
enjoy using
all the time not only because it helps
me connect with others but because i get
exposed to what other people are working
on
and one of the things that is becoming
more and more apparent is that our
social interaction
uh is no longer you know just the
work-life balance is shifting and all of
a sudden a lot of my personal
connections are also on linkedin
and it's all becoming one big you know
one big a
container and mixture and i
constantly am getting both spam messages
and interesting messages and i'm
reaching out to people they're reaching
out to me
and the biggest question you know this
question of building
the right resumes that have been going
on forever our linkedin is essentially
our new resume
so i'd love to spend these 20 minutes
talking about what i can do to maximize
on my
appearance and professionalism on
linkedin but before that sandra i'd love
to talk about
you learning how to swim uh talk to me
talk to me about that
okay so if i want to do something i just
decide somehow i'm going to do it so
somehow i'd manage to become an adult
without ever learning to swim my mother
was afraid of water
so it never let me in the water and i
got this wonderful idea i was living in
thailand that'd be great to scuba dive
but you sort of need to swim before you
a little bit yeah
so it was a little awkward but i had a
pool at the apartment complex and i went
in the pool
and then i never put my face under water
voluntarily
so i filled the sink up in the bathroom
with water and practice
putting my head in opening my eyes and
teaching myself to swim became a scuba
diver even became an instructor
so you know it's kind of been the story
of my life you want to do something
figure out a way to do it so i just want
to paint the picture that you're in the
room and you're filling up the sink with
water and you're pushing putting your
head down
so that you can get over the fear of
opening your eyes and putting your head
under water
yes i just like i've done stranger
things
well if we have time in the end i'll
need to know one more strange thing but
but but then the fact that you're that
you're not only scuba diving but you're
becoming a scuba diving instructor
i think that that's a that's a real
inspiration so that's that's just a
wonderful story
sandra how do you get how did you get
started with your your expertise in
linkedin what do you do to that
well it's almost another putting your
head in the water story
i was laid off from the university of
california where i'd been for 25 years
and at that point thought it would stay
they had other ideas
they pushed me out the nest and who knew
but i discovered i could fly i started
you know the whole
job search thing and going to these
classes to learn
how to do a better resume do interviews
to linkedin
and after the linkedin training people
would be coming up to me saying well
could you just sit with me and help me
you seem to get it and i'm really
struggling
so after about 20 of these people said
you know you're really good at this you
should be charging
so you know i'm in the heart of silicon
valley we're all an entrepreneur i'm a
little late to the game
but i thought why not so i started my
own business
um helping people set up linkedin
so so helping people set up linkedin so
everybody has almost
almost everybody especially in silicon
valley has a linkedin account it's sort
of our signature
like we said when we started out why do
people need help with linkedin
i know why i need help with things that
but i want to know more more with the
general public why they need help with
linkedin
yeah well you'd be surprised there are a
lot of people that don't have lincoln
they've been at companies for so long
they never needed to they just got
recruited from company to company
they never needed to do that and then
all of a sudden
they're walked out the door that day all
of their contacts are on their work
email and they've got to start all over
again so not everyone has one
but also a lot of people just they threw
it up there
maybe they just copied everything on
their resume and they go okay good i'm
done it's there
they're hugely uncomfortable about it
well what should be there what shouldn't
be there
you know what should i do and this whole
social media for the socially reluctant
is what i call it making yourself
comfortable putting yourself out there
online
so not everybody's comfortable knowing
how to do that and then once you've got
it there
what do you do with it how do you build
relationships connections
who should you connect with somebody say
oh i only connect with people i really
know well
well i know about you would that would
need to be 30 50 people for me
oh well maybe i'll connect with people
at work but maybe that would be another
100 or so
so you need to find a comfortable way to
grow your network
and then a way to use linkedin
appropriately so
there's a lot of work in that a lot of
people want to be seen as a thought
leader
or manager of choice because just like
managers are looking at your
um linkedin profile can consider hiring
you
you're looking at them and saying hey do
i want to work for this idiot
am i going to get to work on cool
projects uh
what's his career path being oh same job
five years that means no opportunities
for me
so it works both ways and a lot of
people uh they don't necessarily want a
new job
they want to be recognized for their
expertise so i work with all of them
and um i've i have way too much fun i
shouldn't even call it work
i just love it so so give me you know a
little bit more insight into the actual
work that you do do you do you go on
zoom with them and you
walk them through section by section how
do you draw on previous experiences
do you have are there certain uh you
know uh patterns that you're seeing come
up again
what what are you noticing okay well i
do
work on zoom i screen share i do like a
mini tutorial and overview best
practices
instant out weirdnesses there are a lot
of weirdnesses on linkedin
and then a hand over control to them and
watch over their shoulder directing them
to make changes
but also putting them in control of
their
profile a lot of times linkedin do
things for you they set up defaults
and you don't even know what's happened
you have people like they think they've
got their picture there
don't realize that they've got it set so
no one can actually see their picture
unless they're connected
or they've got everything uh their
public view completely closed so it
makes it very hard to find them
so i make i teach them i'm a teacher at
heart once a teacher always a teacher
um and then i help i teach them how to
do it and
then i polish it up a little bit with
them sometimes they're uncomfortable
it feels like bragging about themselves
so i help them find wording
that feels authentic and appropriate uh
and then
you know how to use this the physical
how to post things
so that you get notice um as well as
that what should you post
why is nobody looking at it when you're
just pushing stuff out there that you
think is great
and nobody cares well you've got to
engage them in conversation
not just push it out of them so teaching
them how to do that is part of what i do
also so so i think it would be wonderful
to hear a few
a few specific ideas of what my friends
and i could do
as we you know as we listen to this
podcast or this interview
we go back to our linkedin what are some
of the common pitfalls that you see
people are making
that that first and foremost we should
be avoiding
okay well one of the most obvious
is your headline right under your name
is an area it's actually
called your headline but the default in
linkedin is when you add a new job
your latest experience title and your
headline it's not called your job title
but linkedin does that to you or for you
depending on how
you're feeling about it and so you are
so much more
than engineer at xyz corporation
owner at you know you want your keywords
plus something about what you do what
you deliver to the company as an
employee
or what you deliver an offer as a
business owner
so headline is the most important thing
when you comment on other people's
content and linkedin
your name and your headline show so it's
like a free advertisement
so that's the number one thing and it's
always been true but continues to be
true
the other thing i would say just one
second about the headline because one of
the things that you know
um my friends and i have been wondering
is that you know we we enjoy taking part
in a lot of different activities that
we're very proud of
we we work at a certain company we are
we we are
you know we volunteer at a certain
organization we study at a certain
school
now and then it stands the question yeah
we could write you know a 50 character
a headline but but at some point i'm
sure that there is you know
there's a drawback and having too much
there or trying to come across as you're
a little pushy
or that you're you're too much in
marketing and less in doing right so so
what is that what is the balance and how
do you find that balance
oh gosh that's the 50 000 question
so linkedin added the number of
characters you could have it used to be
120 characters
mine is actually about 100 because i
liked the way it sat on two lines
they've added now 100 characters so it's
220 characters
which is about four lines in general i
don't like headlines that are that long
if you give me too much to read i read
nothing so i want you to edit it down a
bit a bit like with your advertising or
marketing brain
what are the key things about you and
there's an opportunity in your about
section to tell your story
and that's where you can add in some of
this more interesting content
but in the top you want just enough to
identify your key skills maybe something
a little bit um
interesting about you to make people
want to connect what's different about
you
i mean if i see an invitation to connect
and it says
you know um uh six figures
in six weeks you know i know they're
just going to sell me some automated
product or since lincoln i don't even
bother
so that's obviously to say i'll say over
the top you can talk about what you do
i talk about linkedin profiles for
results which hopefully describes what i
do
but not being very pushy about it so you
have to find that balance
in general i think a couple of lines are
enough
pick and choose what identifies you and
then in your about
section tell me more because the about
section has also
changed it used to be we would go to
your profile we would see the whole
uh used to be was it 1500 characters
i think it's grown to 2000 now it's hard
to keep track but you know do you really
need that much uh and you used to see
all of it and
you could go there and you could see
someone's whole story just by scanning
it
and that was great but we don't see that
now we go to your profile we see the
first three lines
so now you've got that whole marketing
advertising brain you have to use again
you've got to capture me in those first
three lines i don't know
but you've been a silicon valley i don't
reckon anybody
ever clicks on the seymour so you've got
to either have your complete message in
the first three lines
and or be so intriguing that we've just
got to open it and read more about you
so when you how long does it take for
you to to work with a person to really
understand who they are
and what what special thing they have to
offer that would
engage with their other audience or
other people that they want to connect
with because it sounds to me
that a lot of this while there is the
practical you know
understanding the character limit and
setting the settings correctly
the real added value here is
understanding what in terms of marketing
and messaging
gets people to engage with your profile
and your posts right
right that's a great point and um i
use the expression uh walking is really
just
controlled falling the idea being
you put you know you start to fall you
put a foot there you catch yourself you
walk
you start to fall you pick your phone so
on social media especially for some of
us who are a little more uncomfortable
about being online
you've got to take a risk you've just
got to be out there so what i help
people do is be a little brave and pick
the words for now this is not a lifetime
commitment this is not marriage
um this is just pick what's true for now
so i will help people uh identify what
feels right for them
right now knowing that they're not stuck
with it they can change it
i'm just being a little bit brave to do
that and that's really hard for people
so
sometimes you know if you go for
counseling or psychotherapy you go for
months years whatever i work with people
for two hours
and we get it done now sometimes people
will come back to me for additional help
but for the most part
you know who you are right now let's
pick those words
try it out throw it out there and walk
on i'm not going to let you do anything
embarrassing or wrong
um but it's okay you know take a risk
use a word i'm working with a lot of
executive coaches these days
i'm taking an executive coaching program
i've learned that that's probably not
the right thing for me because
coaching you're supposed to just listen
and i want to help you
get it done now also may not be the
right thing for me
um but i work a lot with them and
there's a coach he's so good and he
works in a particular kind of
harmonic harmonic leadership
which is rather unique um
does everybody know what it is no but
maybe they're going to be intrigued and
ask him
so be brave is kind of what i teach i
think is my value ad
so then the the other sections that we
didn't get to touch upon which i believe
is like
the experience the volunteer the awards
these sections are
are you know on the bottom of the page i
personally haven't spent much time
discussing the different organizations
that i volunteer my time for the
different awards
that i received mainly because in my
perception most people are just not
going to scroll that far down or maybe i
have the wrong perception but
but talk to me about these other
sections are they important and if so
what is what is the right positioning as
we approach them
yeah well some of it's like finding
conversation starters
so when you go to someone's profile if
you are both
members of a group or an association
under the
highlights section which is right near
the top it says that you're both members
of this group
or association so right away you've now
got a conversation starter
so that's a really great way to use it
if i do scroll down in your profile and
i see
oh you um volunteer your time
with the boy scouts of america or
whatever it is we've now it's like oh my
kid wasn't my skeleton
i you've got something to talk about so
we're you know constantly looking for
things you have in common
my goal on linkedin is never just to
make a connection
it's always to start a conversation a
conversation that might lead to a
relationship
and a relationship if i'm lucky might
lead to the privilege of doing business
with them
uh for someone in my world my network is
actually quite small i've got about 5000
or so connections
and that sounds a lot to some people but
again in my world that's small
but that's because i don't want to just
add numbers i actually want to have
real conversations with people and i do
i connected with
one of your former speakers after
watching her talk
and told her why i was you know
connecting with her and now we started a
conversation about wine
i love it i just love it so and is there
an
added benefit of having more followers
because i see some people have you know
tens of thousands of followers other
people have 800
what what are the the pros and cons of
of having that
very public appearance of of how many
people
you're connected with and and the
clarification which i need for myself
when it says the number of followers on
a page is that the number of connections
or just the number of people that are
interested in your profile
it's a combination linkedin often uses
the language interchangeably your
connections
are actually the people you're directly
first degree connections with
your followers are people who choose to
follow you because they want to see your
content
but you may not be connected with them
so i've got about the 5 000 connections
and maybe another thousand followers
because i write content about linkedin
and people want to see that
but it it in other places it combines
those two numbers so if i look at your
profile
and i see the number of followers that
would be the combination
in your case probably most of them are
actually connections
so the number the magic number so there
is some value
in algorithmically if they're even such
a word
and having over 500 connections it makes
it i just worked with somebody yesterday
brand new user he's been in an industry
where he wasn't allowed to be on
linkedin
so he literally started from scratch no
connections
and i tried to find examples for him to
look at and linkedin wouldn't let him
look at those examples because
really his reach was not big enough so
of course once he connected with me
he's now only two degrees away from my 5
that just alone gives him more access so
let's say 500 at least just to make it
easy to find people
in general i say people should have at
least 30 connections
for every year of their age so let's do
your own math
you're a young man so that's easy i look
at some people and i see the look of
panic in their eyes as they realize what
that number
is and the reason i use that number is
because you meet
30 people professionally a year i'm sure
why would you not connect with them on
linkedin
so that's like a starting point if
you're in business development you're
going to want a bigger number than that
if you want to be a thought leader and
get your content
when you write content on linkedin you
write a post
it actually goes out to only maybe 10
of all of your connections and they only
see it
in their newsfeed if they happen to be
looking at that time so ten percent of
five thousand
better than ten percent of five hundred
now you can increase that number from
ten percent to more like twenty-five
percent
it's about the max by engaging on
linkedin the more
you're active on linkedin and that would
be the other big thing i would tell
people
they need to be engaged on linkedin my
name
sandra clark is actually very common
there's more than a thousand of me
wow but in general if you put my name
sandra clark in the search bar
i am going to come up as one of the top
six suggested sandra clarks in the world
uh because linkedin's algorithm says hey
you're looking for a center clock really
good chance you're looking for this
crazy lady because she's active on
linkedin
and the guy i was working with yesterday
who had no connections
did that and i came up first i love it i
just love it
sandra you know 20 minutes go by fast
but i i definitely learned a lot and i
have to go back
and fix a few things on my own linkedin
but i'll be looking
thank you very much for the insights and
for for being so generous with your time
before we leave i have to ask you my
favorite question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
okay um i over thought this a little but
you know the obvious ones for me
are mentor and empathetic
and you know after watching more annie's
uh interview
i have to join her with white wine
i love it i just love it thank you very
very much sandra this is wonderful
and uh and and stay safe and stay
healthy especially with all the fires
that are happening today
will do thank you so much a pleasure
talking with you wonderful bye-bye